i'm very pleased to say we're joined
once again on the programme by the
cabinet office minister michael goff mr
goff great to see you this morning um
and of course plenty to discuss as
always but i wonder if we might start
with
uh with pretty patel in the house of
commons yesterday and her announcement
uh well the beginning of the
announcement in terms of controls around
the borders
what do you make of those social
influencers who have jetted off to dubai
at nominally for work purposes at
sunning themselves
on the beach what should they have gone
in the first place for these
photo opportunities and promotional uh
concerns
no not at all
no it's just the the reason i ask is it
does feel rather similar to what boris
johnson is planning to do today
he's getting on a plane or a train he's
traveling several hundred miles all for
the purposes
of a photo opportunity he's not meeting
with the first minister or anything like
that
why is the prime minister heading to
scotland today
i think there's a world of difference
between someone who's trying to
market a product by going abroad and
putting themselves and others at risk
there's a world of difference between
that and the prime minister of the
united kingdom
in the uk uh thanking and supporting
those
on the front line who are at the heart
of our vaccination effort
uh the the prime minister as indeed
nicolas sturgeon
acknowledged in the clip that you played
uh has a responsibility and a role
to make sure that the vaccine rollout is
proceeding appropriately to thank those
on the front line
nhs professionals and those in the
british army uh who are
making sure that things work well and
it's also important that the prime
minister hears from those on the front
line
what is going well and what needs to
improve
no one would doubt the fact mr gove as
you correctly say there is a world of
difference between the cast of love
island on the beaches of dubai and the
prime minister heading to scotland
not least you know there's going to be
fewer bikini photos we certainly hope
for the state of all of our mental
health
but it is a promotional opportunity
nonetheless and nicholas sturgeon is not
suggesting
that it is improper for the prime
minister to go to scotland
what she's suggesting is that right now
with intensive care capacity where it is
with the
the new variant running rampant in the
words of the health secretary
that perhaps now not might not be the
most appropriate time
for the prime minister to do what many
of the scottish diaspora you and i
included can't do
and head home no but the prime minister
like
uh uh other ministers uh is visiting
those on the front line the prime
minister has visited those
uh in our vaccine factories who are
producing the vaccines that
are doing so much to to keep us safe the
prime minister
has visited hospitals in order to uh
thank and support those on the front
line of the nhs
and of course as as you would know neil
part of the job of any politician during
those visits as well as
supporting and thanking the people who
are doing so much to keep us safe
is also to to learn from the front line
you know sometimes politicians are
accused
of uh operating from ivory towers it is
important that all of us
learn from those on the ground uh if
there are uh things that need to be
improved in order to make sure that the
operation of our our services are more
effective
and the other thing of course is that um
when the prime minister visits other
parts of the
united kingdom uh uh other political
leaders
uh don't uh criticize him indeed there's
a welcome for the prime minister and for
other ministers
who are rolling up their sleeves and
getting in touch
uh with those on the ground or making
such a difference
um well in terms of uh the prime
minister heading to scotland clearly
this is the beginning of an effort on
the part of the government
to try and reforge the chains of union
so to speak
how is the government going to attempt
to do this particularly given where the
polling is on scottish independence
well we recognize that uh uh all the
countries of the united kingdom
uh are stronger together when we work
together
um and uh part of that as as we know is
uh the ruler of the vaccine it's the
oxford astrozenica vaccine
that has been produced in the united
kingdom and developed with the help of
our scientists
because the uk has been working together
and there have been people from scotland
wales northern ireland
and england involved in this effort
involved
in supporting our nhs um and it's also
the case
that the the the strength of the uk
treasury
its broad shoulders have been able to
provide a level of financial support to
those most in need across the united
kingdom
that reinforces how important it is for
us to stay together
um and i think you know at the moment
when we're prioritizing the fight
against the disease and also the need
for
economic recovery in due course talking
about you know changing the constitution
and so on is just a massive distraction
i i suppose the question is whether or
not the prime minister himself is is the
best person
to carry that message to the people of
scotland i mean just look at what
happened
just during prime minister's questions
yesterday he accused the scottish
government of dithering and delay when
it came to the vaccine roll out in
scotland
they haven't dithered neither have they
delayed you know he
referred once again to the scottish
nationalist party in full knowledge
that the correct name is the scottish
national party and he mr christine
jordan a lib dem mp for a member of the
snp
and he doesn't think we all look alike
does he uh no the prime minister uh
is someone who is committed heart and
soul uh to supporting the people of
scotland and the people of
uh the united kingdom uh and you know on
your point about the snp
uh they are a nationalist party uh
there's a difference between
uh nationalism but you know you know
what he's doing there you know what he's
doing there mr government he's playing
games
and i'm just saying the tone that he
strikes when he does so he's not
necessarily conducive
to telling people in scotland to remain
in the union i mean they are the largest
party in scotland they're going to
dominate at the next set of elections
and the prime minister you know thumbs
you know
sticks a thumb at them every time he
calls them the scottish nationalist
party how do you think that plays north
of gretna green
well i think for uh those who are in
the snp um who are who are not a
majority
of um uh voters in scotland uh let's uh
let's be clear about that
for those in the snp of course they want
to uh in westminster
in the house of commons make political
points and it's important that those
points are countered
but on a day-to-day basis the uk
government and the scottish government
are working uh hand-in-hand as we are
with the northern ireland executive
and the welsh government just yesterday
i had two meetings
um with the first minister of scotland
uh
cordial business-like meetings in order
to make sure that we were coordinating
our approach
towards the pandemic and that's what
happens every um
every day and every week we work
together and it's the
cooperation between the uk government
and the devolved administrations which
gives people the best of both worlds and
that is something that
uh when they're making their political
points that the snp
uh want to break up uh but
on a day-to-day basis uh that that
shared
working i think is what the the public
want to see
they want to see uh uh politicians uh
whether it's in hollywood or in
westminster or in cardiff
uh cooperating on a practical basis
to deal with the uh the medical
emergency that we all face
we are of course just a couple of days
away from the anniversary of robert
burns birth so it's perhaps appropriate
to quote what some power the gifty gears
to see ourselves
as other seers boris johnson doesn't
need divine intervention to know what
the people of scotland think about him
the polling shows
that 79 of swing voters in scotland
don't want boris johnson to leave the
country so again
i ask the question is boris johnson the
best front man for the union
yes he's the prime minister of the whole
united kingdom and it's important
to recognize that uh the case for the uk
the case for us working together uh is
uh
uh the most important uh uh point of
of of any debate uh when we're looking
at uh how we respond to this pandemic
when we're looking at how we respond to
uh the economy and uh it is the case
that
it is boris prime minister uh who has
been at the heart of making sure
that the uk is leading the world in
terms of vaccine development and vaccine
rollout it's also the case that uh boris
prime minister
has put in place working with rishi
sunek the economic support that is
helping people
in scotland today as it is helping
people across the united kingdom
and the important thing i think is to
look at the
uh the day-to-day reality of the uh uh
the combined strength
uh that the united kingdom brings to
meeting all of these challenges
sure on the topic of vaccines can we can
we discuss the situation as regards your
your colleague um sir desmond swain what
what what message
is desmond sending would he urge his
anti-vaccination campaigners to
to keep going with their fight against
government restrictions
he told them that nhs capacity figures
were being manipulated to exaggerate the
scale of coronavirus he even said that
the government was attempting to
implement social control
uh with his masks policy might you you
know bring your skills of
your powers considerable powers of
persuasion to bear on sir desmond and
tell him to shut up right now
uh so desmond is wrong um you know i
i've worked with sir desmond um i have
great uh
affection for him uh but i'm afraid here
he's completely
out of order is there not though a case
given what we saw in wrexham where the
fit and fill
takes place for the astrazeneca uh
vaccine we saw
someone sent an inert device but a
device to the factory there presumably
from the anti-vaccine community
given that given the importance of the
vaccine campaign
is it not possible is it not is it not
perfectly expectable
that sir desmond should have the whip
removed well i i'd say two things
uh the first thing is uh let's separate
what happened in the in the factory
that's going to be investigated
appropriately
um but uh in the case of what sir
desmond said
uh i would hope that he would uh uh
issue a full and complete
retraction and apology for what he said
it's unacceptable
absent that he should lose the whip then
well
i think that uh the first thing that
should happen is that uh so desmond
should
apologize um and then of course uh
consideration can be given to
any other steps that might be taken but
i think it's important that uh
uh so desmond has a chance to uh retract
withdraw and say sorry for these
comments which as i said
i mean but i'll repeat perhaps the the
gravest charge against him is the fact
that he
suggests that capacity figures within
the health service
are being manipulated he is accusing the
chief medical
the chief medical officer the chief
scientific advisor the legions of people
who work at the cabin office and
elsewhere in whitehall at the moment the
people who put this data together
he's accusing them of lying well
uh he's wrong and he should say sorry
well and again but i will go back to it
but absent that apology
absent the full retraction so desmond
has no place in the conservative party
presumably
i think it's for so desmond to um make
that apology to retract and to
withdraw his words um and i'm sure uh he
will
reflect on that mistake and i'm sure
that uh he will uh be
very clear that it was a serious mistake
and
an apology will be forthcoming and mr
gove i know we have to let you go in a
moment but i just want to ask you again
on on the borders
why have we not introduced a a blanket
rule
looking at the 30 countries on the hot
list one of them not in it
is mexico currently running fourth in
the world for total deaths
17 000 new cases yesterday the best part
of 2000
deaths it rather makes a mockery of the
red list if a country like mexico is not
on it
this morning we'll be uh reviewing uh
not just which countries should be
subject to these new quarantine measures
but also
as you know there are some exemptions
for certain professions will be
reviewing those exemptions
because we want to have as tight a
policy as possible